افادت سلطات ومقاطعه دنيا لروسيا بان
القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت فجر اليوم
انطقت بتروفيسكي في مدينه
صاروخا كانت السلطات المحليه قد اشارت الى
ان القوات الاوكرانيه اطلقت يوم امس 220
قذيفه وصاروخا على عدد من المناطق في
مقاطعه دونيسكو ادت الى اصابه شخصين
بالاضافه الى تضرر عدد من المباني السكنيه
وكانت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت انها صدت
هجمات على ثلاث جبهات في الدنيا
ونشرت القوات المواليه لروسيا مقطع فيديو
قالت انه يوثق استهداف تحصينات ومواقع
للجيش الاوكراني بمسيرات انتحاريه في مكان
لم تحدده في دنيا
دعنا من دونيت مراسله الجزيره كارمن جوخار
كارمن اذا اطلعت على تطورات ايضا في ظل
حديث عن استهداف منطقه بتروفيسكي في
دنيتسكو 20 صاروخا فجر اليوم
نعم عثمان بتروسكي يعيش اهلها يوميات صعبه
جدا منذ بدء هذه الحرب فجر اليوم اطلقت
القوات الاوكرانيه نحو 20 صاروخا باتجاه
تلك المنطقه نحن نلتقي بسكان في داخل
مدينه دانياسك لانه يصعب كثيرا الوصول الى
نظرا الى الاستهدافات المتكرره والقصف
المتكرر يتحدثون عن اياه اياما صعبه
للغايه لا يعرفون متى يبدا هذا القصف
وماذا يستهدف هذا من جهه ولكن ايضا مدينه
دانياسك طالها هذا القصف ومقاطعه ايضا
الحديث من قبل السلطات المحليه عن اكثر
200 من 220 قذيفه طالت هذه المقاطعه وادت
الى سقوط جريحين واضرار لحقت بعدد من
المباني السكنيه هذا القصف ما ردوه عثمان
الى الجبهات المستعره داخل مدينه دنيتك
شماليه مدينه دانيت هناك جبهه افدييفكا
هذه الجبهه تتحدث القوات الروسيه عن مساء
صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه وتحصينات القوات
الاوكرانيه بالتحديد عند شمال غرب هذه
الجبهه اذا ما ذهبنا الى جنوب مدينه دنيتك
جبهتان اساسيتان هما جبهه مارينكا هناك تم
الحديث عن صد هجمات من قبل وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ولكن المواقع العسكريه الروسيه
تقول ان ليله امس شاهدت هجمات من قبل
القوات الروسيه باتجاه مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه على هاتين الجبهتين بالتحديد
بالاضافه الى عدد من الجبهات الاخرى لعل
ابرز هذه الجبهات ايضا هذا الاتصال بين
مقاطعه
ومقاطعه
في الايام الماضيه كانت مسرحا لي هجمات من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه وايضا من قبل
القوات الروسيه اي من الطرفين لغايه الان
عثمان لم يستطع ان يغير في المعادلات
الميدانيه ولكن بالنسبه لقراءه الروس لما
يجري في الميدان منذ اعلان البدء بهذا
الهجوم المضاد يقولون انهم لم اقصاروا
شيئا في خاصه وخاصه هذا من ناحيه الاراضي
يقولون ان التقدم او الحديث من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه عن بعض القرى داخل هذا الشريط
الرمادي او داخل هذه المنطقه الرماديه
التي تشهد كرر وفرا في الايام الماضيه
ولكن يقولون ان هناك يمكن القول يعني
تتقدم روسيا في هذه الناحيه بالنسبه
للخبراء العسكريين وبالنسبه ايضا للسلطات
الروسيه لناحيه الدمار الذي تلحقه هو
الخسائر التي تكبدها للقوات الاوكرانيه
وهذا الامر يمكن ربطه بما تنشروه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه لناحيه العتاد الاوكراني
الذي الحقت به هزيمه وفقه ما تقول القوات
الروسيه شكرا جزيلا لك من دنيا مراسله
الجزيره